bonjour je suis François Xavier
stolsteiner j'ai 38 ans et je suis le
fondateur de sitroom sitroom c'est une
plateforme géographique collaborative
qui permet euh de faciliter la
coordination entre les équipes euh grâce
à un système collaboratif autour d'une
carte
[Musique]
géographique on a fondé l'entreprise en
2020 en octobre 2020 euh évidemment le
projet remonte un peu avant et la la
fondation prise a eu lieu à ce moment-là
et donc on arrive à 3 ans de de création
actuellement nous sommes trois associés
qui travaillons sur le le projet un
associé technique un associé plutôt sur
le développement commercial et
l'international et moi-même pour la
partie gestion et ensuite on travaille
principalement avec des prestataires qui
qui nous permettent de de développer
[Musique]
l'application l'idée initiale elle est
venue de mon expérience je suis un
ancien officier de de l'armée de terre
donc j'ai coordonn des troupes et des
équipes sur le terrain et j'ai je les ai
également coordonné parfois sur le
terrain également à distance et il
manquait d'un outil simple et
collaboratif pour avoir une vision
commune en fait d'une activité ou en
l'occurrence d'une opération donc c'est
vraiment l'idée initiale et et ensuite
l'idée de le diffuser plutôt dans le
secteur privé initialement afin de
faciliter la coordination des
[Musique]
équipes le logiciel en lui-même permet
de produire des groupes collaboratifs
autour de la carte donc l'idée c'est de
permettre aux utilisateurs notamment la
cible c'est les coordinateurs de créer
des sorte de groupe collaboratif un peu
comme un WhatsApp en fait met autour
d'une carte géographique donc on peut
saisir de l'information géoréférencée
sur la carte dans les options
disponibles on peut mettre des objets
connectés pour avoir de la remontée en
temps réel et également on a une sorte
de chat en fait commun qui permet aussi
d'échanger de l'information de manière
très
libre
actuellement on se déploie sur plusieurs
segments un segment plutôt sûreté à
destination des des directions sûreté de
tout types d'organisation donc
typiquement on a un client qui a une ONG
par exemple l'objectif c'est de leur
fournir un outil simplifié qui leur
permet de faciliter la coordination de
leurs équipes sur le terrain mais
également de faire de la veille par
exemple d'événement donc ce segment
sûreté en fait nous a permis de
participer au Trophée de la sécurité en
septembre et nous avons eu la la joie
d'être lauréador dans la dans la
catégorie des systèmes d'aide à la
décision